what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
Oh Rob core Rob core Rob core why do you
guys have to ask for such a difficult
character cosmic armor Superman is a
cool idea it's a cool name and it's like
a really clickbait title but this guy is
so ridiculously difficult to do I wish
you guys had asked for Martian Manhunter
right like that video would be five
seconds long Omega Beyond Omega level
Martian Manhunter dudes just like
Superman he's got two lepa the-- he can
shape-shift and he's afraid of fire
thanks for watching guys peace like it'd
be the easiest video ever well you guys
had to ask for cosmic armor Superman
well I aim to please so we are going to
cover cosmic level or cosmic armor
Superman man I really hope you guys
enjoy this at the very least hey you
better drop some lights to better be
seeing some comments because this is
crazy so the reason why I think this is
gonna be such a difficult care to
explain is because he only has one
appearance that I know of in all of DC
Comics and that's the Superman Beyond
tie-ins to the final crisis event which
was only like two ish years long but
Final Crisis itself is one of the
hardest to explain comics by Grant
Morrison a writer who pretty much known
for writing comics that are hard to
understand now one of the things that
Grant Morrison is particularly obsessed
with is the concept of the DC multiverse
so it should come as no surprise and in
order to understand cosmic armor
Superman we're going to have to
understand the multiverse itself which
I'll try to explain and the least
confusing manner possible
so as far as the physical makeup of the
multiverse is concerned the first thing
we need to understand is that there are
52 individual universes existing
simultaneously within the multiverse now
there are certain characteristics that
these universes have in common like
having different versions of the same
people on each of them but there are
also several factors that make these
universes unique for example the
mainline DC universe that we're familiar
with through modern DC Comics is
designated within the multiverse as
earth zero or earth prime this is the
universe where kal-el came to earth as
the last survivor of the planet Krypton
was raised by Jonathan and Martha Kent
in Smallville and then went on to become
Superman this is the universe were a
young Bruce Wayne sees his parents
murdered in Crime Alley in Gotham City
and decides that it's reasonable to beat
up people in the middle of the night
as a bat the universe designated this
earth 33 on the other hand is the
universe that's representative of the
one that we live in right now were
you're watching this video where people
do not have powers and rasuu be heroes
only exist in comic books movies and
television
so 52 of these earths exist within the
multiverse and they're held together by
a force or an energy called the bleed
which basically takes up all the space
between the universes and of course
that's something we'll refer back to
later on think about it like this if the
different universes in the DC universe
are bricks the bleed is the mortar
between those bricks that holds them
together now outside of these 52
universes which together make up what's
called the Ori of worlds lies the sphere
of the Gods which houses celestial
worlds like heaven the home of basically
DC's God as well as his angels and the
spectre the embodiment of God's
vengeance he'll which is the realm of
the demons and fallen angels New Genesis
the home of the New Gods like highfather
Orion and mr. miracle and even
apocalypse which is ruled by the villain
Darkseid there are other planets within
the sphere of the gods as well but
they're not really important to our
discussion of cosmic armor Superman what
we really need to understand however is
the concept of the monitor's fear which
exists beyond the sphere of gods and is
separated from it by a realm known as
limbo which exists beyond our concepts
of matter and memory and
yadda-yadda-yadda
the monitor's fear is home to an
extremely powerful race of beings known
as the monitor's which we're going to
explain here because they're critical to
understanding how powerful cosmic armor
Superman is originally the monitor was
simply just one guy who oversaw the
entire multiverse and had a counterpart
called the anti-monitor who oversaw the
antimatter universe however both of
these characters were basically killed
during the original crisis on Infinite
Earths event back in the 1980s now
following this the origin was completely
changed so that there was originally an
entity only known as the over monitor
who discovered the multiverse along with
the bleed
now after a while he basically divided
himself into smaller entities called the
monitors each of which were tasked with
watching over one of the 52 universes
now the first of these monitors was
named acts Nauvoo who would later take a
wife among the other monitors named Z lo
valla
and the two of them would have a son
named
NIC's yo tan now after some time Dax
Novi realizes that the monitors can
actually feed on the multiverse like a
parasite and that as a result the
multiverse can be destroyed now after he
reveals this to the other monitors
basically lock him away in a tomb
because he's a crazy person and he
transforms into a villain called man
Drac the dark monitor who's basically a
vampire that feeds off the life force of
the multiverse itself now as man Drac
escapes from the tomb were finally
introduced to the subject of today's
video the cosmic armor Superman so what
happens is that in response to the
threat of man Drac consuming the
multiverse his wife Z lavalla visits
Superman who's waiting by the bedside of
his wife Lois Lane since she was like
really sick and she's in a comatose
state now Z low offers Superman a cure
for Lois in exchange for his help of
course she explains that Lois can be
cured by the bleed but that no one
except the over monitors are able to
bottle or store the bleed now Superman
agrees to help and soon finds out that
zero has recruited Superman from all
over the multiverse included on their
team are over man from Earth 10 a
reality were the Nazis won World War two
captain Adam of Earth 4 Shazam or Billy
Batson from earth 5 and most notably
Ultraman of earth 3 which is home to the
crime syndicate of America basically in
Evil Justice League now as for what
cosmic armor Superman actually is he's
actually a robot that was built by the
monitors to protect the multiverse from
the ultimate evil manderach cosmic honor
Superman is powered by the combined
energy of Superman and Ultraman and is
fueled by memories symmetry duality and
all possibilities and probabilities
that's why you'll sometimes see cosmic
armor Superman referred to as the
thought robot these are basically just
two terms that can refer to the same
entity and can be used interchangeably
but the thought robot is set to exist in
four dimensions and since we can only
perceive three dimensions that means
that the thought robot is untethered by
the bounds of the multiverse meaning
that he's quite literally a day beyond
multiversal level now as far as what
powers cosmic armor Superman has
explaining that is a little bit
complicated due to the fact that he's
only appeared in two issues with the
vast majority of what he does taking
place in the second half of his second
appearance and Superman beyond number
two so first we need to take a look at
what
actually does in the brief time that we
see him and basically what happens is
that he battles Mandrake who again is a
being that is more powerful than
anything or anyone that exists within
the multiverse and he withstands all of
Mandrax attacks and ultimately defeats
him using the powerful energy blasts
that he emits from his eyes and while
that may pretty much be the only feat
that we see out of cosmic armor Superman
the fact that he was able to defeat man
Drac in and of itself means that cosmic
armor Superman is beyond multiversal
level threat which would easily mean
that he's beyond Omega level and since
he's the only version of Superman that
we see that performs feats on a level
greater than the multiverse itself
that's why I said earlier that I believe
he's the most powerful version of
Superman that we've ever seen even
beyond - per man 1 million now in terms
of what cosmic armor Superman's powers
actually are well they're basically
everything he is cosmically a mission
meaning he's aware of everything going
on in the entire multiverse we see
evidence of this in the fact that while
he's battling manderach he's able to
hear a single heartbeat of Lois Lane
which in terms of the multiverse would
have been infinitely small and difficult
to detect he of course has super
strength durability speed flight and he
can create powerful energy blasts all
that stuff is basically par for the
course
but what cosmic armor Superman really is
is a plot device now I don't say that to
be a jerk and to basically be like this
guy's sucks
the reason why I say that is that one of
his abilities is the ability to adapt to
whatever he needs to be in order to
defeat whatever threat he's facing so
whatever powers he needs to be
victorious he's gonna have them which
means that literally there is nothing or
no one that will be able to defeat
cosmic level Superman because he will
simply adapt and equip himself to be
able to defeat it Grant Morrison confirm
this in an interview with IGN where he
equated the over monitor referred to as
the over void and final crisis to God in
the form of a blank page and the over
monitors were his tool of interfacing
between the page itself and what was
written and drawn on it extending this
concept then the thought robot is in
reality just a tool used by the monitors
to undo any changes to the narrative of
the multiverse that they didn't like in
this case it was the existence of
manderach but it could have literally
been any threat that came along maybe it
was comics torreón with his goof
here because Benny has done here but
cosmic armor Superman basically exists
to function as the ultimate retcon able
to alter create or erase anyone or
anything from existence within the
multiverse and so yeah in terms of what
happens to him after he defeats man Rach
he simply kneels down and etches the
words to be continued on a tombstone
that he refers to as his own it's
implied that this is the last time that
we'll ever see him as he's dealt with
the threat of man Drac and is basically
no longer needed Superman and Ultraman
separate and Superman returns to his
home planet and delivers the
encapsulated bleed to Lois
and she makes a full recovery because
when you're Lois Lane that's what you do
so that's pretty much it guys
cosmic armor Superman this is by and
large the most confusing topic that
we'll probably ever discuss when it
comes to the Omega beyond Omega levels
series you guys asked for it so I gave
it to you but cosmic armor Superman is
just kind of crazy in terms of the
things that you can do I mean he's
literally just a guy that can do
anything whatever it is he needs to do
at any given point in time that's just
the way it is so it kind of cheapens him
it kind of takes away for like how
powerful he could be but yeah that's
pretty much it anyway guys we're gonna
go ahead and bring this video to an end
if you are new here too comments
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]